je me disais bien que c'était vous mais
qu'est-ce que vous quelle agréable
surprise mademoiselle style non c'est
anna c'est anna vous êtes là donc
j'avais un rendez vous professionnel à
côté et je les petites bricoles acheter
vous êtes libre oui
comment est ce que je peux vous aider
vous avez des liens en plastique mais
oui on a ça bien sûr si vous voulez je
vous montre où c'est mais je vous suis
mademoiselle style c'est anna autre
chose du ruban adhésif
vous faites des rénovations non nous
l'avons ans de largeur soit simple soit
2 mai un bricoleur qui se respecte ne
peut pas se permettre de ne pas savoir
les deux bien sûr c'est le monde ya les
vrais connaisseurs se font rares de nos
jours et vous désirez autre chose oui
ces cinq mètres de corde
vous faites ça bien vous étiez scouts
non les activités de groupe en règle
générale c'est pas mon truc
alors c'est quoi votre truc je dirais
guinée voilà du ruban adhésif des
attaches plastique cinq mètres de corde
vous êtes le parfait serial killer pas
aujourd'hui